on sean's show he has a game called
truth or dab in which guests either
answer
tough sometimes embarrassing questions
or in a very
hot hot wing so i'm planning on being
super truthful rita
because because reid and i are
masochistic we thought what the hell
let's give it a try challenge accepted
sean all right
well welcome to a very special daytime
edition of
truth or dab the hot one special where
we give our guests two simple options
tell the truth or suffer the wrath of
the last dab today though
mercifully we're using los calientes
rojo
mercifully this is probably gonna be so
hot to me so it's tell the truth
or suffer the wrath of a pretty spicy
wing and i'm thrilled to be here on the
kelly clarkson show
with kelly clarkson and rita wilson
in front of you you guys have three
wings that have all been doused i can
smell the heat
in very hot i know why are you being
like oh we're nice i can smell this it's
like there's a mirage coming off of this
you can see the little way we haven't
even started yet
i'm so nervous shawn i have a set of
deeply personal potentially awkward
questions for you
okay i read you a question you have a
choice okay answer it honestly
or escape the truth by eating a wing
well we'll see how truthful kelly is
here because we're gonna start with you
kelly
fine name one song from a fellow voice
judge
that you hope you never have to hear
again
okay now this is not because it's not a
great song
it's because we ruined it by playing it
too much
i love you john legend i love all of me
but i need a minute
i need a minute i don't want to hear it
for a minute just a minute
and then i'll be fine i'll be fine i
don't want that hot wing i'm risking our
friendship
because i don't want that you go
all right rita on to you okay
what's the best lie you ever got away
with oh oh no oh no
you better eat that you ain't gonna tell
us you ain't gonna tell us
hey let's make some noise
is it doable oh my mouth is watering i'm
so scared
it kind of gets hotter as you start
eating
there's a build on there and you'll see
we do have
some safety nets here oh wow yeah you
have great producers here at the kelly
clarkson show
we have some honey we have some lemon we
have some bread
rita diving into the milk yeah why do
you swallow it it gets really hot
and it stays there and it stays there
you know what it's still burning it's
still
still burning my esophagus i'm so glad i
got my question
you know what okay the questions just
keep coming though okay it's not over
okay i know i'm so ready who was the
worst interview
on your show so far
i cannot tell the truth because my show
just started and i don't want to piss
people off
so here this way do i start here yep
okay
oh man
oh my god it's so hot you are you are
used to hot i'm not used to hot oh wait
it gets hotter
no way yes wait in your nostrils
[Laughter]
oh my god okay everything is fine is
this helpful
i got v8 you tell me
[Applause]
yeah i want to try that oh my god
all right rita while you sit that down
let me ask you this get it in there oh
my god my mouth is on fire you said this
was mild has an afterburn
okay i'm so ready okay read up if you
could take
one credit off your resume what would it
be and why
i know mine from justin to kelly
i'm contractually obligated rita
okay um i think it might be the movie
that haunts me every christmas
jingle all the way now that's right
for a great class you have to understand
i love the movie
but i don't understand my character in
it because why does my character not
understand that turbo man is her husband
like how many superheroes sound like
arnold schwarzenegger
like how dumb is my character like i
don't know i mean it's like it's amazing
at the end of the movie
when she's like he reveals himself and
she goes
howard howard
like hello that was sexy no yes
get it tom subscribe to my channel
subscribe to my channel subscribe to my
channel
subscribe to my channel please don't
make me keep going